wenn sie vom kurs geschickt hätten hätte
ich vielleicht sogar mit ihm gesprochen
aber wenn ich mir brüste umbinden würde
würden sie dann mit mir reden ich glaube
nicht das macht sie nicht attraktiver
[Musik]
es geht los
ich muss ja kurze ende twittern ja ich
weiß was einen kommt ein alter weiser
mann ja ich bin ein alter weißer mann
schätzchen und wenn du einmal ganz nah
neben donald trump gestanden hast war
dann geht dieser spirit auf dich über
und das lässt sich nie nie wieder los
roger trump wird vereidigt und in
unfassbaren massen strömen seine fans zu
diesem feierlichen ereignis egal was
treibt man hält die stange
auf youtube
ein erstes bild ab jetzt aufhören skoda
user inside me and you know that we may
präsident uwe heutiges november 2006 das
transatlantische tischtuch ist zerrissen
trotzdem muss man auf der präsidentin
parade doch mal gucken sojakomplex
donald trump vorbei einer der festlichen
höhepunkte des machtvollen umzugs hier
der prachtvollen parade
hier ist der bus mit den ersten 50
illegalen mexikanischen migranten die
jetzt wieder zurück nach mexiko
verbracht werden ein hübscher einfall
weg vom pöbel auf der straße denn auf
einem der präsidentin bälle trifft man
das edelste was amerika zu bieten hat
einfach nur ganz normale leute
[Musik]
what you think about us cents auf
statement that may be made in the
[Musik]
specials interviewten ist transparent
die warschauer pakt
wie bei ihrer scheidung heißt es am ende
guter trennung wir behalten unsere
gesunden deutschen autos und donald
trump und die amis können ihre
jämmerliche kleine hütte da unten
behalten und damit zurück ins spiel
ist das nicht gefährlich in amerika mit
dem ganzen spendern zu drehen
weißt du ich habe mir extra ganz ganz
schlechtes englisch gesprochen
damit man mich nicht versteht weiß
verbreitung ist alles da das läuft in
der schweiz echt ganz anders ab wir
haben vor kurzem sogar mal eine
reisewarnung ausgesprochen gekriegt dass
wir nicht nach deutschland reisen dürfen
wegen päda und so nahe ist aber du
sprichst ja wenigstens richtig
hochdeutsch aber ich sag mal so ein satz
wie dresden ist montagabend nicht
gefährlich auf schweizerdeutsch dreh
ständig nötig das klingt schon sehr
arabisch gehört sie mit den und ich bin
da in sachsen schweizer
aussenministerium hat der reise waren
bewusst woche und ich bin da wo sie zu
finden
ob es wirklich so schlimm ist
[Musik]
die gipfel jetzt nicht gefällt wie
gefährlich würden sie sagen ist dresden
das kader von 145
[Musik]
deutschland ist ein schönes land weil
man hier schicken kann
in europa wachse würden sie dresslers
gefährlich einschätzen
es kommt darauf an wo man hingeht und an
welchem wochentag menschen mit
migrationshintergrund oder die halt eben
so aussehen als wären sie nicht deutsch
wie sie es immer so schön sagen kann ich
mir schon vorstellen dass sie sich
montags amt nicht auf die straße trauen
wir selbst auch in chemnitz der fall ist
also ist es für schweizer ungefährlich
solange sie deutsch aussehen könnte man
glaube ich so sagen was ist deutsch ja
was würden sie mir raten wie sehe ich
noch ein bisschen deutsch aus schwer
zwischen wenig eigentlich aus der
sitzung tut wirklich wenn ich mache
schon recht gute job der monte waren es
am gefährlichsten
heute abend die damen und herren und die
wiederum freuen
[Musik]
ich bin ein hammer team hier auf dem
platz die sich bei uns nicht angemeldet
hat
wir wissen aber die sind vom zdf heute
show
[Applaus]
in dem irischen ortsversammlung ich
empfehle deutschland wirklich als seligs
folglich bisher sind sie aus trist aber
sie sind chemnitzer ja wirklich die
teilhabe viele chemnitzer ja das war
echt schrecklich was da passiert ist als
die toten hosen gekommen sind ich dachte
mir das ist übel herr das ist also
wirklich schlimmste was man deutschland
bieten können sich jemand als nach oben
ich habe aber auch nicht von nazis
gesprochen ich sage mir so nah weil ja
offiziell das immer so gesagt ja also
der herr zeit dass da in deutschland
kein ort sind was macht den dresdner aus
also wie könnte ich mich ich bin ja
schweizerin wie könnte ich mich besser
integrieren hier
sie brauchen sich gar nicht integrieren
die brauchen nur als normaler mensch
erleben
da war für mich aber als aus afrika wäre
dann wäre das nicht jeder ist afrika es
gibt auch leute aus afrika die nachts um
drei uhr nachts um vier untertrieben
film wir durch die straßen gehen raus
stück verkaufen leute überfallen und
klauen und dessen ausländer ist daher
als asylbewerber gekommen ist der fliegt
bei mir nächsten tag ist er wieder in
der sahara darf ich ein tolles
demokratisches recht wenn ein
rauschgifthändler der hier als
asylbewerber gekommen ist dann schmeiß
ich raus da bin locker ich mache was
jeder mensch machen würde
also liebe schweizerinnen und schweizer
die heime falls sie gedanken in dresden
gibt es verkaufen und dann aber der rest
ist eigentlich sind nicht ungefährlich
ich hab's schweizerin hat für grunder zu
patriotisch zu sein warum sind sie als
deutscher auch gut weil ich deutscher
alt und habe deutsche großvater alles
deutsch ich bin bayerischer abstammung
bayerisches kulturgut klar
wir sagen wir so ich weiß aber dass ich
weiter heisst aber bei uns heißt sie bei
mir san mir
und wir müssen so deutschland stehen
oder bei uns heißt coop schweiz kanada
und rosen
[Musik]
also wirklich nicht gefunden aber ich
glaube ihnen stieß auf dresden ist am
ring stieg und damit zurück ins studio
und du bist da einfach ohne schutz nach
dresden fahren sie mal bist du
lebensmüde hast ja ich dachte mir zur
not hätte ich einfach ins hochdeutsche
gewechselt und gesagt ich liebe
sauerkraut und zack welt mit allen
befreundet gewesen die haben bin ich ja
blendend
trotzdem ich würde das nächste mal was
mit geben in viele schöne blog oder eine
weiter bbk oder klein panzer irgendwas
zur selbstverteidigung brauchst du
einfach gesagt klar kann es sein dass du
einfach mal gerne wieder auf eine
waffenmesse gehen würdest ja sagte ich
einmal da war kommt irgendwo nicht mehr
davon los weißt du waffen messen die
sind für mich irgendwie achtung bombe
hallöchen mein auftrag ist heute für 25
milliarden rüstungsgüter für deutschland
einzukaufen und deswegen bin ich hier
auf der waffenmesse in abu dhabi
was denn
und da kommt so ein scheiß
[Musik]
zivildienst der arbeiterwohlfahrt in
paderborn germany the pace for better in
the weapons and technology germany
ja da wird man jetzt schon verarscht
also wirklich schlimm schlimm schlimm
[Applaus]
[Musik]
denkt man dann blumen mit mir hier wird
also gerade krieg gespielt und wenn man
hier von einer seite short sind das
ungefähr 200 300 waffenhändler mit einer
ordentlichen direktion in der hose
auch eines werdet ihr schon auf die
beiden hubschrauber fliegen es kann sich
demnach nicht um deutsche hubschrauber
handel
wir werden jetzt einmal die
regenbogenfarben gezeigt ich glaube ein
eindeutiges bekenntnis zur gay community
da bin ich mir sicher
oder nicht jetzt perfekt ist so
schütteln laufen momentan die geschäfte
da würde ich keine aussage dazu machen
manchmal so ein bisschen den eindruck
die waffenindustrie ist ein scheues reh
und möchte nicht so gerne auskunft geben
wenn sie konkurs geschickt hätten hätte
vielleicht sogar wieder gesprochen aber
wenn ich mir brüste um wenden würde
würden sie dann mit mir reden ich glaube
nicht das macht sie nicht attraktiver
sn
sind gebeten
ich meine es dazu
die karawane zieht weiter der so denn
dort ist das rassistisch ich glaube
nicht
in abu dhabi eine kleine bescheidene
show
ich hab einfach mal vorbei super
also ich fast noch mal zusammen du warst
in washington
du warst in abu dhabi und ich war in
dresden du in abu dhabi habe ich diese
eine pistole gekauft die hilft mir jetzt
total bei den verhandlungen mit dem zdf
und außerdem ich meine du hast ja auch
bei total geil veranstaltungen zum
beispiel diesem heilpraktiker kongress
also ich könnte mich hier aufregen aber
ich gehe jetzt einfach heim trinken
leckeres gläschen wasser mit mondstein
destilliert dann paar globuli hinterher
sie sind überzeugt wissenschafts
feindlich und sie werden immer mehr ins
gegner aber was sind ihre argumente und
wieso finde ich so viele von ihnen auf
hull praktiker kongresse
was sagen sie zur impfpflicht finde ich
nicht in ordnung weil es
körperverletzung ist also sie haben
keine kinder aber würden sie auch nicht
impfen ja eher tendenz zum nicht impfen
ja eher schauen eben dass das milieu
stimmt dem kind dann würde ich also im
für wurden jetzt sagen gut dass sie
gerne kinder haben ja wahrscheinlich
würde ich sagen ja
yamaha teil davon viele fehler die
einfach krank machen sind durchs immer
das schlimmste krankheit und das ist ja
ein bisschen so als würde ich die post
nur noch per brieftaube verschicken weil
ich mal von der bekannten gehört habe
dass sie per dhl was geschickt hat das
nicht angekommen ist ganz allein mehr
als 95 prozent der leute der impf sind
dann herrscht der herdenimmunität wenn
mehr als 95 prozent geimpft werden
nein es ist ein ganz anderer fahrer das
system ist die frage ja das
gesundheitssystem es fängt mit ernährung
an mit gedanken emotionen partnerschaft
heilung und es geht darum die heilkraft
das sonnenlicht die wir zu den talenten
der pflanzen noch mit in unserem
mittelchen haben wie macht man
sonnenlicht in eine flasche frage
gestellt sind die sonne
hier haben wir ja dieses was die
quartier steht klärung der situation und
verarschung von der chemie gleiche
mischung des unten oder der pflanze wie
es damit typische kundschaft wir sind
natürlich sehr aufgeschlossen
das ist natürlich alles verkaufen dann
nehme ich das einfach und dann reicht
das nicht aus da nicht noch jemand sagen
was ihm vorher gesagt dass sie eine
information zur problembewältigung auch
so ein stein anlagen in mein problem
wäre jetzt diese vehementen impfgegner
das ist ein wirkliches problem dass wir
nicht können sie mich davon heilen ja
das kann ich wir machen das so dass sie
nicht mehr so extrem mit den impfgegnern
resonanz gehen man sollte also nicht
versuchen dass der partner die socken
aufräumt oder das ist manipulation
sondern nur wenn er kommt und ein
problem hat dann können wir das
man muss sich einfach den teil des
gehirns rausschneiden der sich daran
stört dass da sorgten robe liegen zum
beispiel ja sie haben selber eine
tochter die nicht geimpft wurde
sein 20 und würde die oft krank nein nie
das ist aber ja vielleicht weil alle
anderen geimpft sind
das kann ich jetzt nicht beruht also das
ist ja wie wenn wenn alle anderen in der
sauna flipflops an haben und sie gehen
barfuß rein dann kriegen sie auch ganz
ins bild im internet
das ist für mich persönlich entscheiden
kommt und für mich an genau und der rest
soll schauen ja sie sind positiv drauf
wenn sie das trinkwasser sich
halluzinogen nein es ist nicht
halluzinogen und kirche ist fantastisch
als vorbilder
[Musik]
ganz ohne botschaft an den
gesundheitsminister jens spahn es wäre
auch mal schön wenn man nach einer
kinder höre dass die halb durch eine
sünde strenge und harte ausbildung haben
bevor sie auf die menschheit losgelassen
werden
ich hab was probiert an dem stand und es
ist zu viel gewesen
kann das sein ja das problem ist dass
jeder dass die erfahrung dass sein
körper sammeln muss
impfgegner gehen gar nicht gut ich gehe
jetzt nach hause
also ich versuche es zumindest
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was er übrigens auch so eine richtig
heilende wirkung haben soll ist den
kanal der heute show zu abonnieren
das habe ich auch gelesen und auf
gefällt mir klicken ja irgendwas mit
gleichgewicht und innerer frieden oder
so also ich fühle mich jetzt schon viel
besser
ja ja ich auch die nächste folgen des
best ofs gibt es übrigens jetzt schon in
der mediathek solarfirma noch ein paar
globuli schmeißt ja super